- [Reporter] Are you gonna appeal?
- [Narrator] In January, Theranos founder,
Elizabeth Holmes was convicted
on four fraud charges
in her highly publicized criminal trial.
Now Holmes' former top deputy,
and ex-boyfriend, Ramesh Sunny Balwani,
is about to go on trial
for similar charges
of defrauding investors
and patients about the startup's
blood testing capabilities.
Balwani has pleaded not guilty.
- He's a really important
supporting character
in the tale of Theranos.
He was the person closest
to Elizabeth Holmes,
the star of Theranos
for the entire time that
she ran the company.
- [Narrator] Prosecutors say
that Theranos' blood testing technology
didn't work as promised
and that Holmes and Balwani lied
to attract more investments
as the company ran out of cash.
As the trial gets under way,
here's an overview of
Balwani's alleged role
at Theranos, and a look at what's to come
in his criminal fraud trial.
Balwani faces federal
charges nearly identical
to those in Elizabeth Holmes' case.
Two counts of conspiracy
to commit wire fraud
and 10 counts of wire fraud.
- In the end, one of those charges
was dropped against Elizabeth Holmes
due to an error by the prosecution.
It was a charge related to a patient
that had taken a Theranos test.
Although Mr. Balwani and his team
are fighting to get that
charge dropped as well.
- [Narrator] Balwani met Holmes
when she was a teenager
and jointly ran Theranos with her
as chief operating officer.
Holmes and Balwani were also
in a romantic relationship
that spanned more than a decade,
growing and fading alongside the rise
and fall of Theranos.
Former employees said Balwani
enforced a corporate culture
of secrecy and fear
until his departure in the spring of 2016.
- He was not the ultimate
decision maker as she was
but he was the chief operating officer
and he oversaw the lab.
So he had tremendous influence
and tremendous power at Theranos.
- [Narrator] Through
witnesses and evidence,
the prosecution and defense portrayed him
as a complicated figure
who both contributed to and tried
to remedy problems at Theranos.
- So we have a really
conflicting picture I think
from Ms. Holmes' trial
about how much Mr. Balwani
may have contributed
to the many problems at that lab
because of his leadership
and also how much he tried
to perhaps fix some of the problems.
And I think it'll be really interesting
to see the extent to
which that is cleared up
in Mr. Balwani's trial.
- [Narrator] Holmes testified that Balwani
was in charge of the lab operations
and financial projections
shared with investors
as president and chief operating officer.
The defense argued that Holmes believed
she was telling the truth about Theranos
because she relied on Balwani
for accurate information
about the company's operations.
- So there was a lot of testimony to show
that the lab had a lot of problems
and a lot of those problems seemed
to be traced back to Mr. Balwani.
We also saw text messages and emails
and other pieces of evidence
that suggested that he was very
passionate about the company
and really did take efforts at times
to try to remedy the problems.
- [Narrator] The prosecution
also called several witnesses
who revealed how Balwani
treated Theranos employees.
Former lab worker Erika Cheung testified
that Balwani rebuffed her attempts
to raised concerns about
Theranos' technology.
- From the witnesses
called by the prosecution,
specifically former employees of Theranos,
I think we got a consistent picture
that Mr. Balwani is not a nice guy.
He's a guy with a short
temper, a short fuse.
He could be really hard on employees.
He challenged people such
as a former lab worker,
Erika Cheung, about why
she was raising questions
about lab practices.
- [Narrator] The defense and prosecution
also showed hundreds of text messages
that offered a glimpse
into Balwani's romantic
and business relationship with Holmes.
- They show really the complexity
of their personal relationship
and also how intertwined their
personal relationship was
with their business one.
And the messages also show importantly
the influence Mr. Balwani tried to have
over how Ms. Holmes ran the business.
In many cases, it's
trying to correct things
that are wrong with the company.
For instance, saying
we need FDA clearance.
- [Narrator] That 2015
text message referred
to clearance from the Food
and Drug Administration,
which would declare the
company's signature Nanotainers
to collect finger-pricked blood
an uncleared medical device.
In a separate message, he
said that company's lab
was a disaster zone.
- And the prosecution was able
to use those text messages at times
to show that there were
problems at this company
that Elizabeth knew about,
that she was informed of.
- [Narrator] A pivotal moment
in Holmes' testimony came
when she accused Balwani of
emotional and sexual abuse.
She claimed Balwani controlled all aspects
of her life, including how
much she should eat and sleep
and when she could see family and friends.
A lawyer for Balwani denied
the abuse allegations.
- At the end of the day,
she said in her testimony
that well, she blamed
him for exerting control
over aspects of her life.
Elizabeth testified that Mr. Balwani
did not have control over what she said
to investors about the company,
over what she said to business partners
or over what she said to journalists.
- [Narrator] Pre-trail court filings
from Balwani's attorneys
could also offer insight
into what's to come
in his criminal trial.
In one November 2021 filing,
Balwani's defense team
sought to limit evidence
involving patients, including the results
of tests that were performed
using non-Theranos diagnostic equipment.
The judge denied that request.
In order for Balwani to be found guilty,
the prosecution must prove
beyond a reasonable doubt
he had the intent to defraud
patients or investors
about the efficacy of Theranos'
blood testing technology.
- So in the case of investors
that Mr. Balwani told a lie
that was significant enough
that an investor thought oh,
well, that's great.
I'm going to invest in that company
and that might have been
a revenue projection
or a claim about their relationship
with Walgreens, the pharmacy chain
that wasn't true but
that was appealing enough
that it caused an investor
to write them a check.
(dramatic music)